- Troy and I met our
sophomore year in high school,
but it wasn't until the
beginning of our senior year
that I was like hey, I
think he should ask me out.
I'm done being friends, yeah.
On January 1st, 2001,
Troy got down on his knee
and said I was his best friend, and that
he wanted to spend his life with me.
How could I say no to that?
In 2016, I was diagnosed
with breast cancer.
Talk about not knowing what to do.
Troy has been by my side
through every step of the way.
He has cried with me,
took care of our two boys.
He has held me up.
Then in April of 2017, I
was declared cancer free.
Our hearts were just so full,
and everybody was so happy.
And we decided to go to Route
91 Country Festival in Vegas.
(screaming)
At first I heard what I
thought were fireworks.
(ambulance siren)
Troy knew at that time that
somebody was shooting at us.
Troy reached over to get me out,
and we were holding hands
when he got shot in the leg.
Troy not only saved my life that night,
but he was credited for
saving another 20 people.
He was awarded his second Medal of Valor
for what he did that night.
Troy is an amazing man, and I love him
more than any words could ever say.
(audience cheering)
- Well Shannon is joining us now, y'all.
Give it up for Shannon!
(audience cheering)
So in my time spent with you,
this is one of my favorite stories.
Troy was almost the man that got away.
Do you wanna tell everyone how?
- Okay, so just between us,
I will admit it was my fault.
(laughter)
So we were high school sweethearts,
and our freshman year in
college I was so excited.
I'm an only child from
a pretty strict family,
and I was like, oh my gosh.
We're gonna get out,
we're gonna have some fun,
we're gonna go party, we're
gonna let our hair down.
And Troy was like yeah, no.
I wanna be a police officer, I've got you,
you're like my life, I'm good.
And I was like, oh.
I'm like, I don't think I could handle
being married to a cop.
Which was great, because 18.
- All the things you wanted didn't happen.
- It didn't happen at
all, it was so silly.
18-year-old, I didn't
know what I wanted, so
it was a blessing in disguise, because
I got to go do I wanted and needed to do,
and Troy got to follow his path
in becoming a police
officer and everything.
And he's truly my best friend.
- Goals.
So has Troy always been sentimental?
Is he more the sentimental one than you?
- He, well, yes.
(audience laughing)
- That was awesome.
- I can instruct
how to be a sentimental, but he's
really the one that does it.
So even in high school,
he would write me poems.
- Do y'all ever, did y'all get poems,
or did you write any poems?
Ian?
- I write some, my wife writes me notes
all the time and leaves them.
So I have to travel so much
too, but she writes notes,
and little pictures of her and the baby,
and it's really special.
And I find them, like, in a boot.
I mean, she really has
gotten good at hiding them.
- My husband will do that,
he's really good at that.
- [Ian] It's so sweet.
- My husband writes songs for me.
- You know what, pretty cool.
- I find that very romantic.
I know.
- [Ian] I can't do that.
- Yeah I don't write songs or do poems,
so that's why I'm here.
(audience laughing)
- Right, right!
- So you wanted to go big and tell Troy
how much you love him, why?
- I have not been that fabulous, I guess,
at expressing to him how
much he has meant to me
through the last three
years that have just been
roller coasters, up and down.
And he's just my knight in shining armor,
and I just--
- [Kelly] Partner in crime.
- Yeah, and I felt like
reaching out to you guys
to help me just go above and beyond,
and do something to make
him laugh and have fun,
and really feel how much he means,
not only to me, but to everyone
that he's come in touch with.
He's always been such a wonderful person.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, he's a hero as well.
Well, Shannon wanted to go big,
and I was happy to help, 'cause I'm Texan.
So I got together with my band,
and my friend Scott from Pentatonix,
and we all had a musical
brainstorm session.
Hello!
(excited screaming)
This is Scott from Pentatonix.
We wanted to come help.
- Aren't you so sweet!
Oh my gosh, Kelly Clarkson
and Scott from Pentatonix
just walked in this room.
I can't express how excited I am
writing a song for Troy with Kelly's band.
- We know he's like, such
a here it is good dude,
but we wanted to just
get some info from you
from like, like how we
could kinda pull things
like from real life that he'd
laugh at and think are funny.
- To have the opportunity
to share little parts
of Troy and I's life together,
it's just gonna be so much fun.
- So does your husband have any nicknames
that we could possibly use?
- My favorite nickname for
him is Cabana Boy Troy.
- It's also my new favorite name.
- I've written several songs with Kelly,
and most of the time
it's with radio in mind,
or fans in mind, so this is the first time
I've written a song with
just one person in mind.
- [Together] Cabana Boy
Troy, he ain't afraid to cry.
Cabana Boy Troy.
- I love this song!
(group cheering)
- Watching them build this
song about Troy and I's life
is more than incredible.
- So when was your first kiss?
- Speaking of that, when did you have
more than your first kiss?
- Get it, get in there.
- Speaking of a good time!
- Get in there, get in there.
(laughing)
- Lemme just say that, the
movie The Little Mermaid
definitely stirs up some really good.
- [Kelly] The Little Mermaid?
- Yes.
- Not The Little Mermaid!
- Clearly I'm not holding anything back.
- Were you watching it when you?
- Yeah, we were.
- Do you get a certain feeling
when you hear, like.
(steel drum music)
(group laughing)
- Gets the hips moving.
- That's going in the song!
- My new favorite phrase right there.
- Cabana Boy Troy, that, it all works.
- I'm having so much fun
with everyone in this room.
- Oh my God, it'd actually be cool
if it slowed down almost right there.
- Part of your world!
- Or just me and you,
and some kind of like, yeah, duet.
- I can't wait to ambush Troy.
Because he is gonna connect
to every part of the song.
He's not gonna know what happened.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh, okay, so Shannon.
Cabana Boy Troy, first of
all, thank you for that.
That is awesome, it's a great hook.
So how did he get the
nickname Cabana Boy Troy?
- So when we were younger,
I finally convinced him
to start partying with
me, thank goodness, right?
And he is a party and a half.
So any time that we would
have people over to our house
and hosting, he would make sure everybody
was having a great time,
had a drink, had food.
So it just came about, one
time he was bringing a drink,
and we're like oh, thanks cabana boy!
And we're like, Cabana Boy Troy!
That's what he is, and it's
been with him ever since.
- I love it.
(audience applauding)
Well next, with the song all written,
there was just one thing left to do.
Ambush Troy.
So Shannon invited Troy to lunch
at the place they go all the time,
and he had no reason to
suspect anything was going on
other than a nice meal, so just look.
(rapid drum beating)
- Well there's them.
- [Kelly] That's them.
- [Woman] There at the bar.
- Okay, got it.
- We were sitting there,
and of course he's got
Yoda in his lap, so Yoda's snoring.
- We are about to ambush love song Troy.
We're gonna ambush love
song the crap out of him.
It's gonna be awesome.
I'll go, are you Troy?
All right buddy, this one's for you.
Here we go, we're comin' in hot, Troy.
- Go camera one!
Go steady cam!
- April and June are the trial holdings.
I think April and June
are the trial dates.
(restaurant patrons talking)
- What is going on?
- [Kelly] Hi!
Hi.
- Oh boy.
- [Kelly] Hello.
- What's going on?
- Hi!
Oh hey!
Are you Troy?
- Yes.
- Are you Troy?
Oh my gosh buddy, hey.
- Hey.
- This one's for you, big dog.
Here you go.
- One, two three, four.
(group singing in harmony)
♪ Put on that uniform, turn up the heat ♪
♪ A little Disney Plus
is all that she needs ♪
♪ You made a splash when
you kissed the girl ♪
♪ It wasn't long till you
were part of her world ♪
♪ Come on, baby, just feeling her right ♪
♪ She won't remain silent
when you see her tonight ♪
♪ Cabana Boy Troy ♪
- Oh no, he ain't afraid to cry
♪ Sexy hubby's got the booty tonight ♪
♪ Cabana Boy Troy ♪
- Except for when you went to college,
and you were like, oh my god,
we should get married, I love you so much.
And then she was like oh,
marriage's a little big.
'Cause like, maybe we should enjoy like,
our lives, until we do that.
And then it was like, magical
and we're all here now.
Together!
It's great, and!
♪ Cabana Boy Troy ♪
♪ Such a frisker till it ain't even dark ♪
♪ He's the Tim to your Faith ♪
♪ Johnny to your June ♪
Shannon says you're paying, so like,
can we all party with you?
Is that cool?
- Cool, yeah, yeah.
♪ Cabana boy, cabana boy, cabana boy ♪
♪ Cabana Boy Troy ♪
- Yes!
(people cheering)
That's ambush love song, people!
(restaurant patrons clapping)
That was our first
official ambush love song,
and you are our first, Troy!
- That was amazing.
- Cabana Boy Troy, we
heard you like to party.
- I will say, you guys are amazing.
- That was all them.
- That was amazing.
- Troy, I know it surprised you.
Your face was awesome.
I feel like you almost
were like, no I'm not Troy.
I don't know what's happening.
But did that surprise
give you all the feels?
- Oh yeah, that was uh, I don't know.
Thank you so much for doing this.
I just wanna tell you thank you so much.
It is an honor, it's an
honor to be here with you,
with Wilson Phillips, with Ian.
You guys are amazing, that we're even
sitting on this couch right now.
- Hey, we are honored to have you.
You're the hero, you're
the one who saves lives,
and you're getting shot for us.
(audience cheering)
You're the one we
should be saying thank you!
- Well, Tony's the hero too.
There's a lot of heroes out there,
and I think we all just are here
to be the best we can, right?
- Yeah, well we're
supposed to be doing that.
I don't know if everyone's following suit.
It's fine.
- It was an amazing surprise.
I was sitting there, and
Shannon gets me to come to lunch
at 12:30, which is ridiculous,
because I have lunch at 11.
So I'm starving, and I look
right, and you come out.
And I'm like, oh my God.
And then you hit this line from
The Little Mermaid, kiss the girl.
(audience cheering)
And I'm like, oh my God.
- I mean, first of all, we're gonna have
to talk about this backstage, y'all.
Like I'm talkin' Little Mermaid?
- I love Disney.
(audience laughing)
- I feel challenged.
I feel like my husband, I
feel challenged to this.
So you have something that you
wanna tell Shannon though, right?
- Um, so, I've always been a
person who is there for people
and helping people, and
I love my role in life.
But when the person that.
- [Kelly] You're supposed
to feel like this,
that's all right.
- [Troy] Oh God.
- Oh it's all right, it's all right.
Check that out, whoo.
- [Troy] I think I need a hug.
- I'm like a magician.
- But when the person I
cherish the most in the world
puts out that much effort, and helps me
through all this stuff,
I don't know what to do.
It's amazing.
- Aww, y'all are so good.
(audience cheering)
Oh we can share, we can share.
There's more.
I love you!
- I need a hug from Ian.
(audience laughing)
- You are precious.
Get in there, get in there!
- That's good, that's good.
- You kick ass.
- Thank you.
- My gosh, I love it!
Well, we have one more
surprise for the both of you.
- Don't worry, this one won't scare you.
- We're sending Shannon and Troy
to Hilton Playa Del Carmen,
set in the Riviera Maya region.
The all-new, adults only resort
is a perfect escape from every day.
So enjoy all-inclusive amenities,
including international dining,
bottomless cocktails, eh!
And nightly entertainment set
along sweeping ocean views.
Y'all, it's time for a break, but I hope
y'all have so much fun, I'm coming.
I'm gonna serenade y'all there, too.
I'm just kidding!